mr. Peter Collier is an author and
historian he earned his BA and MA at the
University of california-berkeley
former editor of the new left magazine
ramparts he has taught at UC Berkeley UC
Santa Cruz and miles college mr. Collier
is the founding editor of encounter
books where he currently serves as a
consultant he is the author of several
books about famous American families the
Rockefellers the Kennedys the Fords and
the Roosevelt's and also he is the
author of Medal of Honor portraits of
Valor beyond the call of duty which
profiled living Medal of Honor
recipients he is the co-author with
David Horowitz of destructive generation
second thoughts about the 60s so without
further ado let's give a warm Hillsdale
welcome to mr. Peter Coulier
well I appreciate Hillsdale having me I
was here once before and had a great
time I hope you'll have a great time
I've been given licensed by the
organizers of this event to use my
personal experiences and the remarks
that follow I hope they won't regret it
actually it makes sense there's a really
strong consensus about the meanings of
the 60s it's an era that's best seen
through a kaleidoscope really than
through a single lens personal was
political don't forget that part let's
begin with June 1962 since we're talking
about the new left my assignment in this
wonderful College is to talk about the
new left in Vietnam June 62 that's when
a small group of college students who
were members of a newly formed
organization called student students for
Democratic Society an organization whose
rise and fall would define really the
new left
they spent a few intense days at retreat
in Michigan and came up with a manifest
so they called the Port Huron manifesto
of the Port Huron Statement it was a
really audacious birth announcement for
a movement that had big plans for itself
from the beginning and big plans for our
country I should note at the beginning
here that I considered myself part of
the new left and note2 feeling part of
it was easy because it was always really
a tendency rather than organization per
se different from the old left in that
regard
the Communists left no party cards you
didn't have to accept certain dogma to
be a new leftist you just had to see the
world in a certain way I wasn't at Port
Huron in 1962 but I remember feeling
strongly that the document that SDS drew
up there with my sometime friend Tom
Hayden playing a maiden major role spoke
for me I like the zesty impertinence of
it
I like the audacious premise that our
generation shouldn't have to wait for
its middle years as generations
typically do to make a serious bid for
power one element in the new left was
represented by the
diaper babies coming out of the
communist ghettos where their parents
ghettos of the mind really where their
parents had retreated in 1930s these red
diaper babies were comparatively
ideologically sophisticated they were
conversant with Marx and especially
Trotsky although they rejected the
Communist Party for being really too
stodgy and conservative as well as two
solid Stalinist they gave the new left a
facsimile of intellectual rigor the
other element of the new left was
comprised of restless young people like
Hayden and myself whose ideologies was
really basically only a suspicion that
America had given everything in the
world to us except meaning we picked up
on the whiff of subversiveness that was
abroad in America in the late 50s and
was exemplified most explicitly by The
Beat Generation obviously we were driven
by a homemade existential ISM that was
still wet behind the ears
and we believed we would find ourselves
in action the film scene that spoke most
directly to us of all the movies of the
late 50s is the famous one you probably
remember in the wild one where Marlon
Brando plays the head of a motorcycle
gang terrifying a small community in
California was actually Hollister
California and somebody comes up says
what is it you people want he looks at
them with that heavy-lidded Menace that
he you know was perfect at and says I
don't know what do you got that was us
the yearnings of these two strains of
the new left the yearnings they shared
could be heard most clearly in the
opening paragraph of the 1962 Port Huron
Statement we are people of this
generation bred in at least modest
comfort house now in universities
looking uncomfortably at the world we
inherit it's no accident the words
uncomfortably and comfort appear in this
key sentence we were uncomfortable with
what we regarded as the moral deficits
of our appearance word world and the bad
deals that we thought they'd made to
achieve security and cross
Burtie we also question what we saw as
the false comfort of the materialism
which they having lived through the
depression and through war sought to use
as a breakwater against the hazards of
history at its onset the New Left
rejected the complacency and apathy
these are words that reoccur more than
once occur more than once in the Port
Huron Statement
that we saw in our elders lives we were
concerned about alienation
authoritarianism instead of the class
struggle which was a raison d'etre of
the old life we saw ourselves as a
prophetic minority and believed at least
in the beginning that our generational
task was making a lived up to its ideals
we would do this by promoting what the
Port Huron Statement called
participatory democracy one of the key
words of the 60s which would mobilize
those who were left out and beaten down
in our country and give them a say in
the quality and direction of their lives
this 27,000 word document Port Huron
Statement included lengthy and somewhat
abstruse and perhaps simplistic many
many manifestos on subjects such as
values social malaise and university
reform but its immediate targets were
racial and justice and the possibility
of nuclear war we might deliberately
ignore or avoid or fail to feel other
human problems this statement said but
not these two they didn't they demand
that we as individuals take
responsibility for encounter and
resolution so in the first few years
after the Port Huron Statement new
leftist forcas focused really on the
problem of race insisting that it be
treated as an urgent national crisis
moral crisis racial equity the right to
advocate for it's for it was at the
heart for instance of the berkeley free
speech movement of 1964 which is really
a quintessential New Left event
in fact many leftists became Freedom
Riders civil rights workers in the early
60s who would in the
lion's den of the south often at great
personal jeopardy and I think they had
an impact but their other concern the
Cold War and his discontents was more
problematic the new left's pledge was to
be neither red as the old left had been
nor quite red white and blue as our
elders expected us to be we rejected
communism and capitalism more or less
equally as outworn creeds and saw the US
and USSR more or less as equally
threatening to the future we would not
be blinded by patriotism as our parents
generation had been this close to moral
equivalence was at the heart of the new
laughs new to newness really in
retrospect it can also be seen as a
genetic defect that helped make it too
easy far too easy during the Vietnam War
for the new left to reject America
altogether Vietnam was fully on the US
Raider by the summer of 63 when the
first Buddhist monks began to burn
themselves and later on when the diem
regime was decapitated in a bloody coup
the civil rights movement was still the
focus of the new life's attention at
that time but as the new as the u.s.
sent more troops into Vietnam early in
1965 finally abandoning the fiction that
they were merely advisors we became
focused on what was happening there SDS
sorry shield injustice at home and the
war abroad as evil Siamese twins and
initially tried to use the rights that
were the tools of the civil rights
movement demonstrations civil
disobedience public information
campaigns to combat the war
it held teachings they were you know
very influential teaches a series of
teachings in the spring of 1965 and
leading campuses around around the
country I remember what the one at
Berkeley was quite amazing it had
everybody including Norman Mailer who
I actually wound up in the men's
restroom with inadvertently not on
purpose you know and I'm kind of
standing there next to him at the urinal
and kind of God Norman Mailer yeah and I
look over and he said in one of the
great comments anybody's ever said to me
says don't worry well we're all peers
here get it so it held teachings on them
on these campuses during the spring of
65 and it began to counsel for how to
avoid the draft it the SDS actually
organized the march on Washington on the
White House in the spring that drew what
seemed to be at that point an astounding
25,000 people we dream for Vietnam a
vision of a society in which all can
control their destinies SDS wrote after
this March with an upbeat and perhaps
naive rhetoric that seemed almost AB
obsolete at the moment it appeared by
1966 the new left was being gathered up
into larger more amorphous a larger more
amorphous ecumenical thing called the
movement that was always shape-shifting
always on the move very much branded by
the sometimes hallucinatory delusions of
grandeur they characterized the 60s new
leftist were the movements driving force
and brain stem but there were many other
fellow travelers church groups clergymen
other people looking for Navona
earnest young couples pushing babies in
strollers at peace marches that soon
were taking place almost weekly
snick Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee and the Black Power movement
hippies living in a haze of bliss and
sex drugs and rock and roll there were
some good times in the 60s
and yuppies led by Jerry Rubin and Abbie
Hoffman Groucho Marx's we called them
who created the movements radical
performance art invading the balcony of
the stock market and raining down dollar
bills on the traders below showing up at
the Pentagon and chanting in the hopes
of levitating the building and
exercising the evil within when the
Detroit and Newark ghettos became
battlegrounds between rioters and police
and national guards in mid 1967 the
movement saw the face of war the war in
Vietnam in this war at home two
manifestations of one evil the system at
the beginning and at and the beginning
then at that moment of the oceanic
feeling so much a part of the 60s that
all the evils we saw around us were
connected by some sinister synchronicity
I'm going to take a Morial Rubio moment
here and have a little bit of water the
new left had an impact on the nature of
the early debate about Vietnam insisting
absolutely insisting that it was wrong
because it was immoral not because it
was against our national interest I
remember violent arguments with
advocates of the famous political
science scientists of the day hands
Morgenthau position this is a bad war
because it was not a war that could help
our country you know is that against our
national interests the new left wouldn't
buy that it had to be a moral argument
but you know nobody was paying attention
or arguments in this surprise and most
of all enraged us the commitment to
participate the participatory democracy
is so crucial at the new Laos founding
began to fall away democracy was after
all now fighting the most undemocratic
of wars and in any case according to
Herbert Marcuse a-- who became one of
the mentors of the new left at about
this time democracy was based on
repressive tolerance which made it to at
allit Arianism in disguise the belief in
the promise of America which stood
behind the Port Huron Statement was also
wavering America now seemed to be too
many of us what the novelist Henry
Miller had called it
an air-conditioned nightmare the targets
of the new left stepped-up arguments and
actions against the war and this is
important we're never conservatives or
even Republicans they were irrelevant we
zeroed in on the centrist liberals of
the Democratic Party those who were
compassionate on social policy but tough
anti-communist and cold warriors people
David Halberstam later called in his
book about the origins of the war in
Vietnam the best and the brightest
they were the architects of America's
rise to preeminence in the post war war
war post-war world and its entry into
Vietnam we aimed absolutely withering
attack at them and magazine I edited
ramparts which was really arguably the
most I think influential magazine of the
year a small circulation at this peak
maybe four hundred fifty thousand but
modeled itself on Time magazine saw
itself as a four color and glossy new
left publication channeling our ideas
into the mainstream
so we aimed a withering attack at them
and it was repeated elsewhere one of the
kill shots was a 1967 essay by Noam
Chomsky then known only as a linguistic
scholar called the responsibility of
intellectuals this is one of the most
significant and unappreciated stories of
the era the new left's success in taking
down an intellectual and policy elite
that seemed unassailable when the 60s
began by the end of the decade
this elite was absolutely out of
business many of these centrist liberals
had recanted adopting the talking points
of the new left as they turn their backs
on their guilty former selves
some of them would in fact lead the
purge of the remaining centrist liberals
from the Democratic Party in 1970 to
help it to brazenly sees the name
liberal for itself when it had in fact
destroyed what until then had epitomized
the word liberal and then under George
McGovern make the democratic party into
a receptacle for a new left thinking
about Vietnam and
Amerika Jeanne Kirkpatrick and the other
centrist forced on her out of this new
Democratic Party would wander in a
political wilderness until the the
candidacy of Ronald Reagan when they
were finally given an opportunity to
finish the test they had been forced to
abandon which was driving a heart
through the state the driving a stake
through the heart of the Soviet Union
more than 100,000 people came to the
fall 67 March in Washington staged by
the national mobilization community and
the war in Vietnam which we familiarly
called the Mobe the event was a subject
of Norman Mailer's armies of the night
and it generated a lot of attention but
let's noticed but perhaps more
significant was an event that occurred
earlier that week at the University of
Wisconsin when a demonstration there
became the one of the very first to turn
violet causing nineteen police and some
fifty demonstrators to be hospitalized
this is a very large straw in the wind
new leftist were merciless critics of
what we regarded as the administration's
lies about Vietnam that it was being
prevented fought to prevent dominoes
from falling that it was that the
ultimate enemy was the international
communist conspiracy and the biggest lie
of all that we were winning or could win
these lies were clear long before the
Pentagon Papers substantiated we thought
the evils of these lies were so great
that we had a right to create our own
lies penny-ante in comparison of course
to go bat them that the National
Liberation Front Viet Cong was an
indigenous autonomous force of the south
and not controlled by annoy was as an
article of faith absolute article of
faith for the anti-war movement that the
people we were fighting were peasant
nationalists who actually believed in
something like the participatory
democracy we had advocated before we
lost faith in it and that Ho Chi men in
particular who had lived in the u.s.
briefly in 1917 and was said to admire
our history
could have been a friend if only we had
let them that last lie was particularly
particularly tenacious almost comically
so it involved you know dredging up the
fact that he had worked in the Boston
hotel I can't remember the name of it
that had created the Boston cream pie
and in fact he had in his early days
working there been one of the pastry
chefs that helped create the Boston
cream pie ramparts the the radical
magazine where I worked went so far as
to put Uncle Ho on one of its covers
portraying him dressed in Revolutionary
War drag crossing the mekong river with
his cadre in a sampan in a wicked pun on
Washington Crossing the Delaware ho was
something of a fabulous as we all know
who had some estimated some 200 aliases
during his mysterious lifetime he was
many things to many people but he's one
thing for sure
a Leninist he had advocated for
Bolshevism in Asia when he lived in
Paris in 1919 helped form the French
Communist Party the following year was
an early member of Lenin's common turn
and he murdered a lot of people in his
land reform schemes one of the
quintessential parts of the repertory of
communist leaders when he first came to
power
Dostoyevsky once said that famously that
if God is dead all things are permitted
something like that was true for the new
left and democracy if democracy turned
out to be a sham just a high signed a
sounding justification for genocide as
we began to claim when the brutality of
the war mounted then all things were
permitted us in trying to end it
opposing the war justified mythologizing
the blank Black Panther Party a gang of
thugs who rose out of the Oakland ghetto
and hiding their weapons in our
middle-class white middle-class garages
so they could have access to them to
help prosecute their war against the
cops opposing the war justified sending
our new left representatives to
slava in Havana and Budapest in Hanoi
most of all to meet with in more North
Vietnam no North Vietnamese and planned
joint strategy it justified fighting
with the cops in demonstrations it
justified spitting on US troops when
arrived back home I actually saw that
people claim over that's a myth
I saw it several times at the San
Francisco Airport even though there were
no less victims of the war than the
peasant soldier they soldiers they
killed and were killed by although I
didn't voice the opinion of the time
being too much of a coward even I
thought there was something deeply wrong
with white privilege privileged
colleague college kids whose wealthy
families bought them deferments
screaming baby killers had 19 year-old
working-class high school dropouts who
had been the first ones drafted opposing
the war justified trying to burn down
the years at universities which the New
Left saw is guilty collaborating with
the military-industrial complex it
justified revising US history into a
tale of bloodlust and oppression that
began with the Puritans and it continued
ever after without reserve it justified
an assault against bourgeois
individualism as we call it anchored in
the family and anchored by the family I
remember attending a wedding of two of
my Berkeley comrades during the late 60s
they sort of real but parody wedding the
cake was topped with the words smashed
monogamy and indeed this marriage like
so many other relationships became a
soap opera disaster of serial betrayals
leaving behind a couple of children who
later wandered around Berkeley for the
next few years looking like air crash
survivors by the end of 1967 Vietnam was
now in the marrow of the movement we
thought about the Vietnamese when we
woke up we thought about him when we
went home we thought about him we went
to bed talked about the Vietnamese like
they were a particularly earnest and
deserving family that lives somewhere in
the
lower part of our blocks we displayed
Hanoi flags on our windows we were
stoned on the morality of the Vietnamese
in ourselves
I remember once riding in a car with two
of my comrades on the way home from what
we then called street action this war is
actually driving us crazy one of them
said not unhappily the other one smiled
and lazily raised a clenched fist and
said right on 1968 of course was a year
when everything came together and came
apart it was a year of Tet that military
catastrophe that left some 50,000 North
Vietnamese and Vietcong fighters dead
and didn't produce anything resembling
the national revolution had to what Noa
had banked on but was seen as a success
nonetheless because walter kronkite said
it was so it was a year US troop
commitment reached a high point of over
five hundred and thirty thousand in the
year when a majority of americans first
told pollsters they thought the war was
wrong or at least unwinnable the year of
assassinations the year of Nixon's
election and most of all for the
movement it was the year of the
Democratic convention in Chicago where
we staged a bloody riot our cristal
knocked while chanting to the TV cameras
the whole world is watching that moment
and that slogan captured the movements
swaggering belief at the time that it as
much as nations and armies was an author
of history for nearly five years the New
Left had marched to the slogan of
bringing the troops home after 1968 that
slogan morphed gradually into bring the
war home now America began to be spelled
with three K's
not a very subtle reference to the Ku
Klux Klan
I remember once being in the living room
a Berkeley commune about this time when
sheers erupted as Walter Cronkite
announced the number of US soldiers
killed that week as he always did
Friday afternoons the brutality of this
war encouraged us to brutalize ourselves
Marx was suddenly in favor among the new
left's leftists who had initially
scorned him and there is a new fad for
Maoism notwithstanding the fact that the
great helmsman had already killed 40
million of his own during the Great Leap
Forward and would take out another 10
million or so in this Cultural
Revolution just then beginning more
significantly Frantz Fanon's theory of
revolutionary violence he wrote a book
that was huge for a moment in 1969
called wretched of the earth this theory
of revolutionary violence that was now
suddenly de rigueur it may seem
incomprehensible looking back at it
today but Newsweek made a possible
revolution in the United States into a
cover story in 1969 we were similarly
too deluded we believed in the words of
the Jim Morrison song that became a sort
of anthem for the movement then it was
time to break on through to the other
side it was in 1962 9 also there was an
uprising in Berkeley over rights to a
strip of land the university owned that
was in this riot became known as the
People's Park demonstrations it was a
huge moment in the history of the
revolution that we thought was about to
be born
at its height at the height of this
fierce confrontation between law
enforcement and demonstrators there was
a meeting of the Politburo if you will
of the street action led again by Tom
Hayden who was a sort of everyman of the
movement Auriemma he said should be to
follow the example of Vietcong and
established liberated zones first in
Berkeley than in Ann Arbor and in
Madison than in Cambridge and hooked
them up into a rough draft of
revolutionary America the Black Panthers
who were already locked and loaded would
be our vanguard in the battles ahead our
Ameri
Kong as Hayden put it he asked David
Hilliard then the Panthers Minister of
Defense to shoot down one of the police
helicopters dropping pepper spray on the
People's Park rioters Hilliard shot him
in one of the great moments of the
sixties shot him a contemptuous look but
that just a withering look and he said
just like you Tom
get a [ __ ] to pull the trigger more
significantly 1969 was also the year
that students for a Democratic Society
one of whose brightest stars Hayden had
been at the beginning finally flamed out
in an ugly factional fight in its final
National Convention that left the group
that became known as weatherman and then
the Weather Underground in charge of the
Tattered Remnants of the organization
then after issue a manifesto that said
their intention was to fight US
imperialism and create a class of
classless world of communism thus
turning the New Left back into the old
left Bernardine Dohrn and Bill Ayers and
all the others went to Havana for
instructions and came back to the u.s.
amped up to begin their bombing campaign
we're going to shove this war down their
dumb fascist throats when weatherman
said at that point we're gonna kick ass
what SDS had been in its beginnings an
organization seeking to America to make
America live up to its promise and what
it began become late in 1969 a
brain-dead call to violence actually
issuing a formal declaration of war on
America this will always be for me the
story and minuscule of the sixties in
the 1980s particularly when what
remained of the movement let's call it
the leftover left tried to stage a
second coming in order to defeat the
Reagan administration's efforts to block
communism in Central America there was a
renaissance of interest in the 60s but
then is now the nihilistic extremism
that appeared at the end of the era was
airbrushed out of the picture by the
left's apologists if there were excesses
oh well these were understandable given
the provocation of
war but if they were except that there
were excesses they were few and far
between the anti-war movement was
basically comprised of idealist who
wanted nothing more than to give peace a
chance there were indeed such people far
more of them there were of the hardcore
leftist but at the ground level and in
real time it seemed that the radicals
called the tune and they did the dance
how real were the attractions of radical
chic well I got an insight early in
nineteen sixty seventy when after a
couple of weeks after I had written a
story in ramparts about the Indian
Alcatraz Indian occupation of Alcatraz
excuse me I got a call from one of Jane
Fonda's camp followers this person was
in Europe and said that Jane had left
her french director husband Roger Vadim
and was doing meditation in India with
the Maharishi yogi but after years as a
film debutante and sex kitten she wanted
to come home and get some authenticity
into her life would I help bring her
into the movement and would I take her
to Alcatraz much my wife's dismay I of
course said yes not realizing I was
about ready to give this vein and
vacuous woman who subtracts from the sum
total of human knowledge every time she
opens her mouth a cause and an identity
I met her on San Francisco Pier one
morning and a private yacht took us to
Alcatraz she was in her shag cut
Cloutier's very earnest very much the
quick study when we got to the old
prison she saw immediately that there
was a power struggle between the
hardline Sioux and the other tribes for
control of the island and immediately
went off to smoke dope with the Sioux
warriors as they called themselves in
their part of the compound soon after
she was on her off on her magic mystery
tour of the movement to the Panthers to
the GI coffee house movement and
ultimately of course to Hanoi itself
sometimes she muff muff her lines
as in the appearance one night on the
Dick Cavett show when she committed the
classic spoonerism spoonerism in saying
that the war there in Southeast Asia was
being fought by the u.s. to control the
tongue and instan of the area tin and
tungsten get it did you get it shake her
head but she quickly learned to walk the
walk and talk the talk and frankly
nobody did it better
Vietnam gave fonder her most memorable
still shot atop that anti-aircraft gun
aiming at us fliers it gave her a most
memorable commitment comment which was
her most memorable line which is when
she said that they were these POWs were
probably war criminals and they were
lucky they weren't being prosecuted just
simply being held in beaten half to
death and he gave her a most enduring
role the one she'll always be remembered
for after the other ones have faded into
celluloid dust annoyed jayden in the end
when the last US helicopter left Saigon
with all those terrified people
desperately clinging to its skids we got
pretty much everything we wanted the
North now controlled the South the US
was not only defeated but humiliated
beginning at a retreat that wouldn't
enable the USSR to launch an
international offensive for communism
over the next few years but with
Southeast Asia the heaven on earth we
believed it would be when Hanoi finally
won Oh contraire it was a hell a hell of
tiger cages and political reaction camps
and summary executions boat people
killing fields of Cambodia as Richard
Nixon memorably said more people killed
in the first three years of the
Communist Peace than in all 13 years of
the anti-communist war some of us with
Joan Baez of all people playing a
leading role tried to make the horrors
visited on what had been South Vietnam a
mad
discussion in the movement a fraternal
metal matter of discussion not a matter
of you know acrimony or a split but just
this should be on the radar we shouldn't
you know let's let's encounter this a
little bit the response we got was the
old communists lap down there aren't any
enemies on the Left we were told to shut
up in effect and begin fridging toward
the next utopia in the Horn of Africa
Central America wherever although it
would take years for you fully to
accomplish this this is when I myself
began to leave the loved the war in
Vietnam was desperately wrong in the way
it was justified the way it was fought
and the American lives that had chewed
up and the indiscriminate carnage he
caused among the people of Southeast
Asia it really was a heart of darkness
and it taught less daunting lessons
about our nation but taught lessons
about the self as well for me the
summary judgment came on all those years
came one night at Elaine's which was
then the fashionable Manhattan watering
spot for the literary industrial complex
I guess yeah some of us had gathered
there just as the 60s was going on 70s
and Willy Morris named this kind of now
forgotten but was important at the time
he was the editor of Harper's Magazine
major liberty literary figure of the day
no particular friend of the war he was
there also
I saw him he was at the bar he was
watching us for a while looking at us
obviously in his cups
he kind of lurched over to our table and
looked down at us and said in his
Mississippi draw you know the problem
with y'all the problem with y'all say
you didn't love America enough and then
he walked back to the bar he was right I
see my old comrades now and then the
hand fall fall who still talked to me
they too are shuffling through their
golden years but one thing still burns
bright for them despite the night that
approaches
and that is the good old days when we
were all so bad they take comfort in the
belief that the movements ideas not the
ideas of the new left at Port Huron but
of the later more exciting more Rococo
phase have by some perverse twist of
fate not only survived but triumphed
they see this victory in the
universities Hillsdale mirabile dictu is
an exception which were the radicals
after their long march through the 70s
late 80s now control things and have
made into a citadel for snowflakes and
safe places for grievance groups and
indoctrination sessions including
attacks the attacks du jour on whiteness
you probably have seen those whiteness
is down there giving courses in
whiteness unlike the courses in all the
other minority groups which are
affirmation courses the courses in
whiteness our attack courses these are
these courses on whiteness eerily echo
the weatherman attacks 50 years ago on
what they call white skin privilege
attacks that permeated the movement and
why shouldn't they they echo weatherman
former Weather Underground leaders Ayers
Bill Ayers and Bernardine Dohrn after
all who surfaced from their bombing
campaign after a few years was scarcely
a sigh upon the risk and certainly with
no remorse whatsoever bill air is one
you know once told me for a story I was
writing is it you know really about the
time he came up he said looked at me
says Oh guilty as hell free as a bird
America is a great country
the guy does irony pretty well came up
after a few years years was scarcely a
slap on the wrist and certainly with no
remorse and they were able to pick up
their lives without missing a beat as
influential professors in influential
universities it's one of the great
travesties of all time they should have
been tried for treason my old comrades
can see a victory too in the media which
glorify organizations like black lives
matter and give credence to their line
that our nation is fatally gripped by
our racism that gets more homicide
every year that we come more distance
from slavery and by predatory misogyny
that never arrests and most of all they
take heart in a democratic party which
is now an integral part of the left and
filled with the same contempt for the
deplorable --zz that we ourselves had
back in the day for those middle
Americans who didn't particularly like
the war but hated how we were trashing
our country so there you have it the
song of the 60s is over but the melody
lingers on thank you
[Applause]
mr. Collier has agreed to sign copies of
his book destructive generation second
thoughts about the 60s directly
following the lecture in Philips Lobby
we now have time for a few questions
please raise your hand and a microphone
will be brought to you okay my question
I call it as a under seal this movement
that we're having right now in the
United States against from and now it's
rich the rich left what are we not now
what are we supposed to do I know what
we're supposed to do is stand up to them
and tell them to go to hell but what
what can we keep on doing you know our
children I have grandchildren and I want
them to learn what's what did happen
thank God they go to the Academy they
all hear some of it but you know we got
public school that just could care less
about that part of our history and where
we went wrong well I think you're right
about that actually all these things
kind of come together bill errors became
a quote unquote distinguished professor
of childhood education at the University
of Illinois Urbana one of the campuses
Eddie I'm sorry Chicago okay I thought
it was one of the outlying campuses and
he really was incredibly has been he's
retired now and been pretty influential
actually in taking the ideas I mean that
the the conquest of the university was a
fete accompli by in my opinion pretty
much by the 90s the long march through
the institution's a phrase that was
coined by the German New Left it's Rudy
Dukie you know that is we've lost now
for the time being you know when the
Vietnam War was over and they kind of
the air went out of this thing this
revolution we've lost but what we need
to do is begin a long march through the
institutions and the institutions that
were most available were the
universities
which we had tried to burn down of
course in the 60s and we went back to
get on the tenure track in the 70s and
80s and so it seemed to me by pretty
much by the 90s I taught at Berkeley you
know actually in the late 70s early 80s
for a while and I could see the change
kind of coming over it and it seemed
like him perhaps a lost cause and they
they the new left or the left theorists
exemplified by Ayers pretty much felt so
assault so as well so they'd began an
attack really k-12 education and that's
where all the firepower is right now you
don't have to worry about taking you you
have hegemony in the Universities let's
move on k12 is where it's at that's
where he you know he's imported the
hostile Marxist ideas of some Brazilian
theorist named Paolo Ferrari and you
know he wrote these textbooks
influencing not only in classroom type
education but most of all the education
of teachers that is teacher training
very smart very new left and that's
where the attack is now I mean it's on
k-12 education and I think it's
absolutely surprising it's a hidden
offensive hidden intellectual and
political offensive that is now if you
want to if you want to chill yourself
start googling you know indoctrination
in k-12 education I mean it's pretty
amazing I mean I don't know textbooks
teacher training and the teaching the
teaching profession has become much more
vulnerable to these ideas now it is no
longer a sort of moderate profession
it's you know it's been infiltrated over
the years by people who have a mission
you know I have kind of a personal thing
but I mean kind of a silly story but I
have a five-year-old who's in a pretty
exclusive private school in Hollywood
yeah
I asked him what they did for Christmas
and he said well we learned songs about
Kwanzaa
I said Kwanzaa there's one black kid and
out of in the whole school
you know school costs $17,000 a year or
something my son is a madman and Kwanzaa
I you know I got hysterical and I wrote
a letter that my son will be mailed to
them you know pointing out Kwanzaa is a
bogus idiotic concept that was begun by
a black radical named Ron Karenga
moulana
Ron Karenga in 1966 it was created out
of whole cloth this guy did six years in
jail for torturing two women and he
became the Godfather of this movement
created out of whole cloth called
Kwanzaa I'm thinking if this you know if
this exclusive school in Hollywood
California this is telling these kids
didn't you know you can imagine where it
is honey you know the black people I
think African Americans are too smart
for this stuff only white people are
stupid enough for this stuff you know
it's something like I think it's
something like just a miniscule number
less than 5% of black people on
celebrate Kwanzaa that's what I read on
perhaps I'm wrong about that but I'd
make sense
african-americans are Christians you
know say it again this story gets worse
and worse my son so cowardly that he
wouldn't let me send the letter so
because he was afraid there would be you
know reprisals against my five-year-old
grandson don't get me started as my
mother used to say another question yeah
I was there I thought Jimi Hendrix Janis
Joplin Jim Morrison Churchill that said
if you're when you're young you're a
liberal oh and you get older you're
conservative they think anyway clearly
that's happened to you and I wonder if
that hasn't happened to the people in
Berkeley although they haven't realized
it to stop Coulter and Annapolis from
speaking at freedom of speech square on
the campus I don't have any question
exactly except that you taught there and
how what is that they can feel that
they're not misunderstanding the idea
and committing the same sins themselves
it's just we're dealing with sénèque
titude here inadvertently I have to
admit that I hearing is not can you
summarize for you holding the microphone
the question is is that in Berkeley when
you come at the end of Telegraph Square
there's a big open area in the campus
and there's the freedom of speech area
with the little platform that you can
get up and talk but the and the the what
what used to be if you looked up in the
dictionary liberal art really anymore
and they would tell told Coulter to
leave and innopolis not to show up and
we're burning buildings to stop free
speech in the very place where
supposedly was founded
and it's so absurd but I don't really
have a question exactly except ahead
maybe have you comments about how that
is reflecting in the way the country is
going the Free Speech Movement kind of
lasted for about a year and you know if
you want to see a place where free
speech is ruthlessly repressed you
should go to Berkeley these days I mean
there's a probably the most malicious
organization on campus in America called
the students for justice in Palestine ho
ho there you know controlled the public
dialogue there about the Middle East
ruthlessly a Tyson medic and you know
it's a tough place to go against him
they have faculty members of you know
one of their faculty members is guy
named Hayden Bayesian aptly named Hayden
Bajan who actually founded the students
for justice in Palestine and you know
he's actually made Berkeley into a place
where you know the Nakba which is the
alleged catastrophe which was actually
the founding of Israel the alleged
catastrophe for the Palestinian people
were that's the big you know kind of
anti-jewish hate fest every year it's
not it's not a friendly place to spree
speech anywhere on campus today in my
opinion in fact it's not only that
there's kind of sanctions against the
people who who speak on correct thoughts
it's the idea I mean even you know the
idea of free speech itself is you know
being challenged as a virtue and that
goes back I mentioned Herbert Marcuse ax
this whole idea he had of repressive
tolerance you know he really actually
laid out the the ground rules for how
you attack free speech free speech is
actually counterproductive and certainly
counter-revolutionary
when it advances you know bad ideas so
it must be ruthlessly repressed
therefore you have things like you have
you know basically the you know the
special forces of the the anti of the
left today are these Anti Fog
people on the streets beating the hell
out of people who say incorrect things
you know there's stormtroopers you know
the left is all talking all about you
know Nazism and you know fascism and
stuff like that of course you know these
anti-fascists are the biggest fascists
of all right back there
we'll do a question over here
real quick and then we'll get back to
you oh I'm sorry
thank you for speaking mr. Collier my
question for you is this was there any
one specific event that led to your
departure from this new left movement or
was it a culmination of things any one
event that did what that led to your
departure from this it really was this
whole thing about Vietnam you know those
of us who were perturbed back in the day
there was his principal called
internationalism we were
internationalists in the interests of
internationalism it seemed to a handful
of us and again Joan Baez has to get
really tremendous credit here you know
she really led this you know we had an
obligation these were our people in
South Vietnam even though they were seen
as counter revolutionaries they were the
Vietnamese after all they're getting
slaughtered in political reaction camps
they're getting drown and you know the
season of South South China Sea you know
we want to talk about this at least and
say come on where we were we off base a
little bit on how we we romanticized
Hanoi you know and that that was what
started but be aware that it's not a
momentary thing you don't say hey that's
it I'm out of the left you know being
part of the left and the reason it is
such an effective movement is like being
part of a church and the sanctions
against apostasy are huge and so you
know what people typically do is they
like what David Horowitz my friend and I
who have moved in lockstep through life
for the last 50 years what we did was
you know let's let's dig a foundation
here and retreat only to here we're
still loved us yeah that won't work
here here and then it's a free slide you
know I was telling the wonderful speaker
you're gonna have in a couple of hours
today that you know I always think of
that great poem by Dylan Thomas about
the death of his mother and the refrain
is after the first death there is no
other now what Thomas met of course
was that the first time you experienced
death as a person the first time you
experienced it it is so definitive that
the deaths that come you know will never
surpass it and its impact well I always
thought I've come to think that after
the first doubt there is no other that
first doubt the seed that has planted in
you when that doubt if you you have a
shred of authenticity that doubt is
going to lead to other doubts and
finally the whole thing will collapse
one of the problems with the left is
that it doesn't let those doubts ever
you know come in it you know has a very
effective immune system and prevents
those doubts from happening so this took
David and me to get out of the left it
took about seven years and it involved
all kinds of other things like at
ramparts we had a book keeper that we
allowed the Black Panthers to use
because they had some weird kind of
offline enterprises or was a place
called the lamp post which was a bar
down in the down in South Berkeley and
we allowed them to kind of use her to
kind of straighten out their books they
were getting audit and everything and
she she actually found out that they
were laundering drugs this is it this
was a group that was a black version of
Murder Inc basically and they were
laundering drugs and all kinds of other
stuff anyhow as a result she got killed
they killed her they murdered her and so
that was a huge you know because you
know the left is a gang you know where
did stolen come from he was a bank
robber he had a gang that robbed banks
the gang metaphor is pretty strong for a
lot so to answer your question it's kind
of a process I think and so that was
true with the previous generation not to
compare any any of us to any of them but
the previous generation the left of the
of the 30s who the God that failed left
you know Arthur Kessler and Richard
Wright
Aundre she'd that recanted I mean this
is the same for them although in
comparison to them were dwarves standing
on the shoulders of giants and anyway
you had a question back yonder
unfortunately we have no more time Thank
You mr. Collier okay
[Applause]